see y'all Abbas getting right now I'm
triggering nothing because it's in my
head
triggered because I'm like
who raised you exactly
no shame there's like difficult
conversation that you have to have where
it's like bro you don't need a handout
you need somebody to slap your hand
every time you grab your credit card you
pop in bottles and you ask it for
Hangouts that's crazy all right today's
topic
money family and friends because I had a
situation where someone who I wasn't
very close to I've asked me for some
financials what are your thoughts my
rules is based on something that my mom
told me don't lend money that you cannot
afford to land when you land money
consider that money gone it's a bit like
when you're playing at the casino
don't play with the intent of hey you
know what I'ma make my money I'm gonna
make my money back no you lose though
it's fun the fun is to bet but that
money that you bet is gone okay now when
I lend you that money
when I lend you that money I'm gonna
lend it to you I'm never gonna say I'm
not gonna be the one that's gonna say uh
giving me give it back to me
by this time of that time when I lent it
to you my money's already gone in my
head
I'm you have to listen to someone and
sorry Google alert somebody owes me
money
I ain't you [__]
I hate you
I I gave you money on your time you
gonna give me my money back on my time
I see what you're saying and I was I was
I was exactly like that for me my money
there was a particular person
just the way you said it the smart
particular person was like yeah I'm in
the wrong thing I'm wrong with the wrong
pass in my life and everything and stuff
and I'm like all right cool lend them
some money
I'm gonna give it to you back by that
time and I'm like all right cool don't
hear
squat diddly about the person no nothing
no when the date passes nothing
[__] come up comes back to me
and be like oh
um what happened was I'm in another
predicament and I need your generosity
to blah blah blah blah blah and in my
head I'm like
[__]
yo there's no way you can't even talk to
them talk to me about the money that you
on he's like oh by the way I didn't
forget about the other thing I'm like
you can't even talk to me about that
other money that you already owe me bruh
no he called you an old fool and said
hey you down to be a new fool you know
what I mean
bruh I might be stupid but I'm not crazy
all right
stupid but I ain't dumb
that's what she gonna say so I was like
hey I no I got other things to take care
of like you haven't even settled the
first step and even when I said when I
said no she was on that tip where oh I
cool I'll get you I run you on your
other money never heard about the
[__] again when we cross each
other in events and [__] I'm gonna talk
about yo let me offer you a drink no I
pay my own drinks I'm good and now you
see all I was getting right now I'm
triggering the [__] out of it because
it's in my house
triggered because I'm like
who raised you exactly you know what I
mean like there's so many layers of this
Behavior that's so [__] bizarre to me
I could never at any point in my life
get to a situation where I was asking
people who wasn't in my really tight
circle from any of the people in my kite
circle like my my brother my mom my best
friend from all even them I'm really
reluctant it makes me uneasy and I'm
trying to pay back ASAP cause of the
shame I feel and then you got
[__] who not only asking people
just like that but you know they never
gonna pay that [__] back and they're
gonna feed you lines and and like how do
you walk through life with no shame
and I see you at the club popping
bottles I see you taking [__] on dates
I see you taking trips I see you buying
designer or other dumb [__]
and you live it with that shame I could
never here's the thing I've made that
mistake now I'm speaking from experience
I've lost people over it
because I thought they were spitting in
my face
you know what I mean I work hard for my
mind I always had since I was 17 I've
been having jobs I've been paying all my
I've been living on my zone so I I know
the value of a dollar I've always saved
on minimal income so when my people ask
me for money because they ain't a pinch
you know I guess I'm like yo I'm here to
help I'm a generous person I got you
okay but don't disrespect the the
generosity that I show if I'm giving and
you taking it for granted I'm taking the
whole [__] away and I never want to give
you anything ever again
I'll give but just don't make me look
like a fool forgiven you understand what
I'm saying we all want to go to Cancun
you know graduation part we all want to
go
homie Abdi this name is Abdul [__] this
thing I don't care I'll say his name
Abdi okay all right yeah you already
know one of them big forehead I don't
care I'll say it damn he asked me for
money this okay and I want him on the
trip too go ahead you know my paycheck
is coming in before the trip but you
know I need the money but he's like yo
this is my deadline and so you give it
to me I can run it too because I'm
getting my paycheck before so I can run
you back them I said cool
I got you I want you to go on the trip
dude never runs me back to cash I said
it's cool when you come back you're
gonna run it to me go on the trip enjoy
yourself I'm gonna just work and get
some more money you enjoy The Graduate I
I abdicated I mean I have to go
[__] comes back don't give me my
money back and I'm looking at it I'm
like bro I didn't know you since I was a
kid are you serious
when you edited me I was there in a
pinch and now I see you at the club I
see you doing all this other [__] and
you and you want to shake my hand
I could do a lot I'll tolerate a lot
you can't spit in my face and then give
me a hand after you
who raised you
I met your mom it wasn't her
nah bro that [__] it just it's so
insulting it's so insulting
I already told my Exodus Max she has
somebody to that took her money I said
listen I'll come to the family reunion
but don't expect me to be cool with this
[__] I won't say nothing but if
you come up to me we not we're not
getting along I can't it's so disgusting
to me when I see people do [__] like
that
so now in my latter years like if you
need me to if you got an emergency let's
say like something happened with your
child let's say your home gets Blown
Away by a tornado something like really
bad happens to your family I'll just
give it because you're going through a
tough time that's fine but don't come
under the guise of I'm struggling you'll
run me some cash I'm gonna pay you back
we come to some kind of understanding
and then you just go and insult me like
that I don't I don't I can't do it and
also people who are that comfortable
just quickly coming to ask somebody who
they don't know that well for money I
just find it a little uneasy because I'm
like don't you have family members or
really close friends yet you can't ask
and if you can't why is that that's a
red flag and a half why can't you rely
on the people closest to you for this
kind of Kiss is it because they know you
a liability or is it because you can't
foster those kind of relationships
what's going on there why are you asking
distant people and you're in a place of
real desperation or are you just a
person who's full of red flags and a lot
of people seem through it and now you
just run through the list and now you
went from first contacts to Second
contact now I'm I'm thinking about them
things I don't know maybe it was just
the way I was raised but I would just
feel so much shame associated with
asking for this kind of cast I just
don't understand it but maybe it's my
blindness and I'm just seeing things
from my point of view so you know I have
to admit that this is a situation or a
topic that triggers me for sure yeah
yeah absolutely absolutely and I I
really used to be like that but it was
affecting me so much that I had to
change my mindset it's like if I if I
lend you some money and you acting like
that and this and that the social media
thing I don't really take too seriously
but if if in an instance I see I see you
acting certain way and you do that I'm
here from that guy
ever let me tell you this I don't have
to I don't have to give you a reminder
all right I don't know if that's the
reason why but I'm I'm
I think it's my reason
I'm too old for this [__]
you know damn well what you did you then
you know damn well what you said I'm not
gonna be hearing me nah I'ma watch you
do your thing imma watch you do your
thing and it's okay I ain't got I don't
even feel hate towards the dude but it
used to affect me like that it don't
really eat at me because I just don't do
it it don't that's my No I don't because
I just don't do it I don't oh yeah you
don't name [__] yeah that's my
solution right unless I know you know
you know you
no I've seen so many relationships go
south because of these kinds of Dynamics
so I just prefer not to involve money
period and the truth is even if I had
your attitude I could never look at that
person the same so why am I going to
give money so I can hate you afterwards
why am I going to give money so I can
look at you like yo this person is
untrustworthy unreliable and also
disrespectful not well raced if you out
here are borrowing money and saying
you're gonna pay it back and you don't I
gotta look at you like yo you got some
trash behavior in you sorry that's just
me when somebody pays it forward to you
under the end of saying that you're
gonna pay it back right and you just
spit on that something wrong with you in
my opinion I would rather starve than to
live like that that's me though the
thing that happened is that whenever you
land on top of that family members you
know you let family members some money
that could be very [__] serious
because they're going to take that [__]
for granted they gonna you know bigger
sisters older sisters younger sisters
you make some money they really think
you owe them that because you're blood
related or whatever or not oh even worse
it's like you you might be enabling
something really terrible somebody you
know because you open the door once when
they're not they're going through a hard
time but not one that's super difficult
you know what I'm saying they're going
through like a struggle and then they
come to you to help them out of that
struggle and then it becomes a thing
where it's like you don't find or build
any methods for you to get out of it
yourself you just start relying on these
means that's why a lot of people were a
little bit too comfortable asking for
money start asking for it again like
that Shameless [__] I'm in a
pinch no no no it's like I don't know to
me I got to see that you're doing a lot
of Labor by yourself and that you really
made a long journey for before you can
start asking people for them handouts in
my opinion you know the thing is I think
that some people need to break their
face first and foremost rule number one
you can't save everybody you can't
something that had I have to say to
myself every day you can't save
everybody right some people to learn to
understand to grow they need to break
they face
they need to really feel this version
and getting their lights cut off and
reaching a low you need to reach the low
sometimes sometimes helping someone is
actually not helping them absolutely
you're just enabling them to do even
worse you're not helping them I just
want to help you no no no no no no no it
does not do that it does the exact
opposite because a person always have no
matter what happened no matter what
happened someone came through and was
able to help and after that what they're
going to do they're gonna turn around
and say it was God every time I wasn't
that bad it was God that saved me yes
maybe it was the devil
maybe it was the devil enablingly okay
if you believe in that sort of thing all
that to say
you're not helping the per but sometimes
by helping someone you're not helping
them hey some of the people who ask for
money are always asking for money it's
just some people just that's their ammo
it is the thing that works they know how
to work on their relationships and the
kind of things that they Foster they're
constantly asking for and the way I see
it is
maybe my relationship with money was
really different but I've always learned
how to manage my cash flow and to be
responsible with it and when I'm handing
folks that cash they're not building the
skills necessary for them to manage
their money well they're not
understanding how they're spending which
creates a lot of the deficits that
they're encountering the struggles that
they're issuing with themselves and a
lot of people don't want to have that
conversation but it's not even an income
issue for some people if you just look
at these bills it's like
how the [__] are you Uber Eats it when
you got anything 40K a year and you
ubereats are multiple times a week
there's like difficult conversations
that you have to have where it's like
bro you don't need a handout you need
somebody to slap your hand every time
you grab your credit card
you need somebody to slap your phone out
of your hand every time you try to buy
some [__] online that you know you don't
need buying clothes that go to your
closet you never wear you know and it is
tough to say [__] like that because you
don't want to micromanage other people's
lives but it's like how you going around
asking for money when you even haven't
looked at some of the deficits that
you're creating on your own with nobody
else around you I love that [__] I love
that [__] when they're talking about
when you you when you and when you walk
up to them and you'll be like yo well
you should be doing all that [__] yo
mind your business my my business it's
my business if I keep on lending you
money and then I see you do some dumb
[__] like that it is a hundred percent
my business stop doing that dumb [__]
yeah you should hold your friends
accountable if they're your friends I
was poor probably until like
age 28 29. I mean making below 35k year
every year but I knew how to stretch my
cash though I knew how to situate myself
monetarily whether it be with roommates
whether it be with public transport
whether it be with mocking my ads to
places whether it be with cooking all
the time buying in bulk doing everything
I can to make sure I maximize and
stretch my dollars and I don't know
about y'all but I'd rather be doing that
[__] than asking people for [__]
handles that is just how I am you're the
dude that I know that is the most
impressive with that [__] I gotta I
gotta admit listen even the income I
make today 98 of it goes straight to
savings or goes to the business I don't
touch it okay but that's how I'm built
and why I'm saying this is I'm looking
at people who are asking for money and I
see the indisposable income they got
like 40 to 50 percent of their cash and
they still spending it dumb by the end
of the month they got nothing left it's
just it's stuff I look at where I'm like
bro you gotta look at that before you
even ask me for a dollar
you popping bottles and you ask it for
Hangouts that's crazy that's crazy that
is crazy you at the club buying multiple
drinks for girls and yourself and you
asking me for money a [__] a bottle
that has a markup of like
600 this is one department where I am
very inflexible in a lot of times but
I'm like some of y'all need to get some
shame in your life that's all
some of y'all need some shame here
anybody want to come oh Abby you can say
that because you bro I I've been poor
vast majority of my life I've had
roommates my pretty much my whole adult
life not because I want to do out of
necessity not the greatest life but you
know what I made it work and thankfully
I've got a good roommate situation but
it's like I did what I need to based off
the income I made same but I I slept
well knowing I wasn't asking everybody
that I didn't owe a bunch of people so I
didn't have credit card debt I didn't
have this debt or that debt I'm not that
gives me some peace same I had a
roommate all my life was my girlfriend
but whatever
you're pretty good
what's up
no no man me I would and I was not good
with my money before
my God I was not good with my money
before and I'm gonna tell you this I I I
was one
I'm right here saying this to y'all
don't even take it as I think I'm better
than y'all don't even think that I'm
better than y'all it's not even that so
what's that in mind hopefully you guys
appreciate today's video we want to talk
about something a little bit different
you know what I mean but yeah you guys
like today's topic let us know what you
guys think in the comments below we want
to hear from you
[Music]